the left-wing media gets it wrong so
many times it's really hard to keep
track
but the new superstar at the podium is
keeping him in check
cnn's chris cuomo said show me where it
says protesters are supposed to be
peaceful
well i'd point him to the first
amendment where it says that you have
the right to co-peaceably assemble he
should go back and read
the constitution i think um you know
you're asking the wrong question the
right question is where did
where did the data ask haley so please
where did you ask
and i answered your question once but if
you ask it twice it doesn't make it any
better of a question
did anyone take it upon themselves to
pose any questions about michael flynn
unmasking the president obama's
spokesperson oh not a single journalist
has posed that question
you know i was asked probably 12
questions about the confederate flag
and i'm a little dismayed that i didn't
receive one question on the deaths
that we got in this country this weekend
not one question
i didn't received one question about
five children who were killed the
president say the parents out there
who are now going okay what do i do with
my kids
now the president has said um
unmistakably that he wants schools to
open uh the science should not stand
in the way of this of course we can do
it everyone else in the western world
our peer nations are doing it
the science is on our side here after
that last exchange cnn reporter jim
acosta took to twitter to take a jab at
kaylee mcinerney with this
the white house press secretary on
trump's push to reopen schools quote
the science should not stand in the way
of this
try again jim we just saw the proof that
you took her words out of context
joining me now to set the record
straight white house press secretary
kaylee mcinerney all right so kaylee
everybody saw what you were saying is
the science is on the side of opening
schools
and the science shouldn't get in the way
of reopening schools because
the science supports reopening schools
but then
he comes out and reframes what you said
to make you look
bad do you ever just see him walking
around and
kind of stick a finger in his face and
say jim what the hell are you doing
hey i see him around he's actually quite
nice off camera
which is interesting but look it's it's
an admission that they can't debate on
the merits jesse and look this is the
equivalent
if i was to say to you right now there
is no universe
in which jim acosta engages in fake news
and you put up on your chiron
jim acosta engages in fake news it would
be the exact opposite of what i said in
selective editing
but that's exactly what jim acosta did
it was false and it was wrong which is
why he corrected his tweet
you know i've heard that about jim i
heard when the cameras go off he's a
nice guy and then the lights come up and
he's
a total maniac um a doctor heckle and
and mr hyde situation another guy that's
kind of uh
crossing you is jonathan carl now he
runs the whole white house
correspondents association and deal and
he's really mad
kaylee he's mad he doesn't like the way
you run the briefings
he wrote this really angry column in the
washington post and he basically says
you open these briefings like you're
doing a cable news monologue
and you're really not doing your duty
you're not informing the public
what is your response to that yeah he
likes to talk about the public trust in
his op-ed well guess what i use my
briefings for
i use my briefings to highlight issues
the american people care about
that they don't ask about when have they
asked me about police officers dying in
our streets
children dying in the streets of
democrat cities these are democrat
cities two individuals who died in chop
the democrat
autonomous zone when have they asked
about this they don't ask about it
and it's why i look over the reporters
directly at the camera and speak to the
american people because these issues and
these lives matter and john carl
he wants to determine how he wants to
run the briefing no one's stopping him
from trying to become press secretary in
a future administration
he could have been press secretary for
the last administration that would have
been that's right a better fit is he one
of those guys that's nice when the
cameras go off like jim or is he just
mean all the time
hey john's nice too these guys a lot of
them are very nice off the camera all
right so it's a performance i totally
understand that
now you also got into it you've been
getting into it with lots of people
recently kaylee
i guess the chicago mayor hates you now
her name's lightfoot
you said i guess she wasn't really doing
her job let's listen to what you said
it is unacceptable and under this
president he'll take action in the
derelict mayor of chicago
should step up and ask for federal help
because she's doing a very poor job
at securing her streets all right so
then what did you
i think she tweeted hey karen watch your
mouth
yeah karen's supposed to be some i guess
slang for
a bossy middle-aged white woman
i don't know you don't even look
middle-aged you look younger than that
but
um what's your response to the mayor of
chicago
yeah my response is that i'm very upset
about the violence in the streets of her
city you know she's focused on words
but instead she should be focused on
action because you know right now
uh this weekend what we'll see is
hopefully not but what we've routinely
seen
are double-digit numbers of people dying
in her city so she needs to focus on
securing her streets i understand the
truth hurts
the president's written her a letter and
offered her help and she needs to take
it because it's inexcusable
when children die and the democrat-run
seat streets of chicago
uh mayor light light uh mayor lightfoot
excuse me
yeah should be focused on that
lightweight light foot whatever you want
to call
it i mean it's homicides are
skyrocketing i think they're having the
deadliest
year so far in 25 years so it's not good
to be
living in chicago right now so the
president
is pivoting to the economy after kind of
a rough start to the summer we're seeing
things reopen
um he's wearing a mask now we're going
to talk about
masks in the next segment and
in your opinion looking forward to
august and then september
what is the white house doing in order
to bring this country back to full
throttle
yeah a lot look this is the jobs
president we're focused on phase four
which will be a great spill assuming the
democrats come to the table that give a
tax break to middle income
americans lower income americans payroll
tax holidays what the president wants to
see in that
and more funding for our schools to
reopen you look at the vaccine you have
one vaccine that's entering phase three
trial this president
has broken down barriers and paved the
way to move forward
and to get through this pandemic and to
restart the economy it's a stark
contrast to democrats that want to lock
our children away
keep them out of schools uh and they're
ignoring the science which says it's
perfectly okay to do
yeah if you can get a vaccine and a tax
cut within the next couple months
i think every single american would be
thrilled with that news all right kaylee
mcinney
tangling with all sorts of characters
all over the place
stay safe out there thank you jesse